how's it going people
i am dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message for
february 24th 21 2021 my entire team for
the last
10 minutes just had an insane laughing
fit i feel like i have like tears in my
eyes still at the moment because someone
sent me something
that was absolutely hilarious a former
sitcom star sent me something that was
incredibly funny and we had to debate
for 10 minutes whether we could play it
the video because it would it would
bring down
the angry cancel people on me i don't
think i'm gonna play it today
but i think we may play it tomorrow
because
uh all right we got a great show for you
today you know yesterday's show
i did four stories and it was just like
endless stupidity after endless
stupidity about the media
and fouchy and masks and lockdowns and
everything else so i thought today we're
just gonna
mix it up a little bit differently and
try to hit a few different things but
there's just
there's just so much stupidity out there
and i hope
that if you give me this you know 20 to
30 minutes a day
uh that you feel a little less dumb
because
as i tell people all the time if you're
watching cnn it's either making you
dumber or angry or like who's watching
an
hour of don lemon and comes off feeling
smarter
or more enlightened you pretty much feel
dumber or angrier and that goes for
cuovo and and pretty much all of it um
so i hope that we don't do that around
here and that this is
worthy of your time which i sense that
it is by reading your comments and
hearing
from you guys uh quick reminder guys you
can get 30 off your blaze subscription
your annual subscription
uh this ends this sale ends on friday
night february 26 in just a couple days
just go to blazetv.com you don't even
have to enter a code and you're good to
go
uh the four stories that we're gonna hit
today
first off the guardian posted a hit
piece on me yesterday it's been a while
since i've had a mainstream hit piece
calling me far right but they did it and
we're going to talk about that
what's old is new again how nice you
know it's been a while i was kind of
feeling left out you know nobody's
called me alt right or
far right or well the usual twitter
losers do but i mean i haven't had like
a mainstream
media go for it in a while so that was
kind of refreshing uh also
are we going to ban grand theft auto
because of auto thefts
well we'll find out biden's trans
health and human sex human services
secretary
uh is now advocating for puberty
blockers on young teens which this is
obviously one of the issues
that even though it affects just an
obscenely tiny amount of people that's
not to diminish
the the importance of dealing with who
you are and all that kind of stuff
uh for some reason the trans issue seems
to be paramount on everything else and i
think is a really linchpin of
why everything is so out of whack
culturally and then finally
you may remember two weeks ago we did a
couple episodes uh
where i showed you throwback clips to
ronald reagan on the johnny carson
tonight show
and people really loved it and i loved
it because i felt like it frames a
little bit
about today by seeing something from the
past
so there's a clip that's been going
viral on twitter for the last couple
days
uh from ron paul uh you guys know ron
paul the
former congressman from texas uh who
also is the founder of the tea party and
he's been basically the leading light of
libertarianism
in america for the last couple decades
he was on the morton downey junior show
in the mid mid late 80s i would say this
was and
uh and get got into a little fractus
with somebody and it's just worth
watching because it makes you realize
that the things that we're dealing with
now
although they seem crazier and at some
level they are especially when
you know i just mentioned this trans
issue like when we see these things that
start
really sort of spinning out of control
everything seems crazy but
it's good to look at some of the stuff
in the past and realize oh people have
been fighting about all of these
ideas forever so we're going to cover
all four of those before i get to it
people
i want to talk to you not about bill
barr the former attorney general
i want to talk to you about built bar
i've got the coconut almond in my hand
right now
if you're having trouble avoiding
leftover candy from valentine's day
i've got just the solution for you built
bar is the secret to eating healthier
food while also eating tastier food
built bars are low calorie low sugar
high protein high fiber
great for the keto diet i can actually
lose or maintain weight while indulging
in a yummy treat
healthy has never been this delicious
built bars taste like candy and come in
18 amazing flavors including
caramel brownie and peanut butter i've
got the coconut almond right there
built bars are covered in 100 chocolate
include both nut and nut free flavors
and are soft and easy to chew
i know with restaurants finally opening
up it'll be tempting to indulge but we
also need to shed those additional
quarantine pounds
which is why pill bars are the perfect
alternative to pie for the health
conscious guy
each bar contains 110 to 160 calories 16
to 20 grams of protein
and three to five net carbs it's only
february guys don't give up on your new
year's resolution
built bars are the answer go to
billboard.com and use promo code ruben
to get 20 off your next order
use promo code ruben for 20 off at
billbar.com
and now back to me i'm going to take a
little sip of coffee
so there was a hit piece it's been a
while it's good to be back everybody
there was a hit piece uh written in the
guardian
uh and it was basically about
uh sky news australia now one of the
hosts at sky news australia
uh is a friend of mine and a former
guest on the show her name is rita
panahi
rita was actually born in the u.s but
grew up in iran i had her on the show
years ago i've done her show in
australia a couple times when i was on
tour with jordan peterson in australia i
did her show in studio i've done it
on skype a few times rita is an
incredible
voice for what i would say is old school
liberalism if you want to call it
current day conservatism but
individual rights freedom free press
open inquiry
all of those things that are now thought
of as far-right
and alt-right ideas right uh so i love
rita i think she's
she's an actual journalist which is very
rare these days she's an excellent
writer also
and i highly recommend you follow her on
twitter i think it's just
rita panahi but in any event she hosts a
show
that she's one of several hosts i
believe uh called sky
after dark and this is where they
interview all sorts of people from all
over the world and i've been on this
show a couple times
and we talk about the usual stuff that i
talk about here in any essence the show
is obviously picking up some steam
and uh as you know australia is having
all sorts of crackdowns on things right
now you probably heard over the last few
days
facebook has taken out a ton a ton
of free thought and libertarian leaning
and even centrist basically non-woke
facebook pages have been annihilated off
facebook so they're having major
censorship problems they're having all
sorts of lockdown problems like we're
having here in the united states and
everything else
but obviously the show sky after dark is
picking up some steam because what
happens once you start doing something
sort of outside of the mainstream and
even though sky news is a giant
corporation
you know there's always sort of shows on
these networks that are a little outside
the mainstream right remember red eye on
fox
news that's where gutfeld sort of got
his start and it was like it was like
whoa where these guys
do these guys even realize they're on
cable tv well there are shows that are a
little looser a little more fun
anyway i don't want to make it all about
the show in any event i've done the show
a couple times
and uh the title what was the title of
the article do we have the title here
it was uh sky news australia
is tapping into the global conspiracy
set
and it's paying off very very scary
stuff
uh and then here's the quote about me
which i just thought was great and i
hate to
i hate to make the news about me but i
just thought this perfectly illustrates
like the
the never-ending nonsense that we're all
kind of dealing with these days
quote the sky after dark team also
regularly
interviews far right figures who have
big social media followings in their own
countries
recent interviews have included the
reform uk
parties nigel farage katie hopkins the
uk
commentator who was banned from twitter
for hate speech
and u.s political commentator and
youtube personality
dave rubin now first off
nigel i i like nigel i got drunk with
nigel in the morning once
in the uk in london that was fun we had
a couple big gin and tonics
and then i gave a speech over at oxford
union the most important speech of my
life
which i actually think i nailed even
though i was a little buzzed i knocked
back like three
shots of espresso right before i did it
you can find that online if you just
search my name and
just search dave ruben oxford union
anyway katie hopkins i've also had on
the show she's a bit of a flamethrower
for sure no doubt about it
but and us political commentator and
youtube personality dave rubin and they
are describing us all as far right now
that's all it says about me in the
article it does not go into any
not even one of my political beliefs my
far right
political beliefs i did write a whole
book i've got it back there
defending old school liberalism anyway i
only mention this
not even really because i care you know
years ago when these things would happen
all the time right they were always
happening to jordan
and they were happening to to ben
shapiro and they were happening to sam
harrison a whole crew of people
it's like we all get that the mainstream
media is awful and basically at this
point i mean
they've done something so dangerous here
because they've really cried wolf to the
point
that when the wolf shows up when the
really far right person
shows up and they will by the way and
they exist obviously
uh and what i mean by that is someone
forget far right specifically
when the really racist person shows up
when the really
xenophobic person shows up when the when
the real authoritarian shows up
no one's going to listen anymore because
you've run around and called people like
dave rubin
far right so years ago when this was
happening virtually every other day
there was a hit piece written about me
on mother jones or daily beast or huffpo
or any of just these awful publications
that are all now floundering right
and and we all know it uh it used to i
used to feel like i had to fight it and
i'd be arguing with twitter
people and usually you know tons of you
guys would would come to my defense
which was great
it's been a long time since one of these
happened probably about a year for me
so i just thought this was worth
mentioning because uh
maybe in your life i suspect that you
get it like when when you were to come
across an article like this and they
just say someone's far right
and they don't even say why they're far
right or anything else it's like well
you know that
but it's important to really understand
it so that when your friend says when
your friend sees scary dave rubin on
your
on your iphone you and goes would you
listen to far
right dave rubin well you you have sort
of the ammunition
to go ahead and say well not only is he
not far right and
wrote a book defending liberalism but
this is the way
that mainstream media deals with people
they don't like and that's really what
this is about
by the way i i tweeted this morning i
found the the author of the article
sometimes these articles are
completely anonymous the author did have
her twitter name attached to it so
i did ask her to clarify her statements
and let me know if i
do hold any far right opinions uh you're
not going to believe it i did not
hear back from her okay anyway moving on
i want to talk to you guys
about end guard watches i've got one on
right now it's pretty
it really is pretty beautiful look at
this thing can you see this thing it's
really nice
uh the ceo of egard watches has used the
brand to make to take a strong stance
against censorship and continued
lockdowns with incredibly powerful video
which with an incredibly powerful
video called what is freedom which has
gone viral you guys absolutely should
check it out on youtube
it's a real synopsis of a lot of things
that i've been talking about here for a
long time
their tbl watch is a functional sturdy
reliable piece designed to honor
our law enforcement egard stands proudly
with our law enforcement officers and
are proud to give 15
of all profits from this piece to law
enforcement charities
watches are undeniably one of the most
notable ways to express
yourself perhaps the most historic of
all accessories
all egard watches are incredibly unique
and well crafted
whether you're an avid watch where or
you're finally coming around to the idea
of adding a designer watch to your
wardrobe
there are several different styles and
movements that you can choose from
visit eguardwatches.com use discount
code ruben to get 15 off your next
timepiece
that's eguardwatches.com discount code
ruben it really is a beautiful watch
and a bunch of you guys actually have
have purchased the watch and
posted your your wrists and your time
pieces in the reuben report community so
i love seeing that
as well okay let's talk about grand
theft auto you guys know
and i don't like to brag around here but
yes i was assistant manager
of electronics boutique which is now
known as gamestop
which of course became you know a huge
wall street situation a couple weeks ago
i was assistant manager of electronics
boutique in broadway mall in hicksville
long island in 1999.
i moved a tremendous amount of red
pokemon
tremendous amount of yellow pokemon you
could not get video games on long island
if you didn't go through me i know a
little something about video games okay
well an illinois democrat by the name of
marcus
evans he wants to ban grand theft
auto claiming that grand theft auto
the game that i'm guessing many of you
have played i used to have grand theft
auto vice city i think it was on
playstation one
and yes you can you can carjack
somebody's driving down the street you
can just run into the street
stop their car pull them out of the car
take the car you can also punch hookers
you can blow up helicopters all sorts of
stuff
he seems to think that all of the bad
stuff that you can do in that you can
shoot random people
you know you can steal things
flamethrowers god
god only knows what else you can do he's
very worried that
kids are playing that game and then
going you know i just carjacked in the
game
and i'm gonna i'm gonna do a little car
jacket in real life
by the way there's no evidence before i
even read the quote from the daily wire
there's no evidence that video games
cause violence you know this was a thing
for many many years you guys may
remember
20 years ago when uh it was joe
lieberman and john mccain were leading
this fight to get mortal kombat out of
video game stores
and then there was this huge it was a
really interesting thing there was this
really uh
big fight between uh sega and nintendo
when mortal kombat came out on the
consoles
because in the arcade there was blood
everywhere sega said yeah we're going to
leave the blood in
nintendo wanted to be a little more
family friendly they got rid of but the
point is
nobody in the name of mortal kombat ever
froze somebody
then ripped their skull off with their
spine attached to it
and and finished them nobody's done it
nobody's done it so video games don't
cause violence there's a lot of studies
that prove it if anything they've proven
that they actually lessen violence
because you're able to get
some of that angst and that rage and
that stuff that we've all got
you're able to get it out of your system
in a healthier way but the daily wire
did a piece on this they said
uh chicago illinois has seen a spike in
carjackings
in 2021 even though carjackings in 2020
increased more than 135
compared to 2019. so 2020 went up 135
uh more than the year before to combat
the spike that they're suddenly seeing
again
an illinois lawmaker has proposed
banning grand theft auto
a video game that has had a new entry in
almost a decade
the chicago sun times reported that
evans new bill
would amend the 2012 law to quote ban
the sale of
anyone of video games depicting
psychological harm
including motor vehicle theft with a
driver
or a passenger present the bill would
also
amend the definition of what constitutes
a violent video game
to include one where players control a
character
within the video game that is encouraged
to perpetuate human on human violence
in which the player kills or otherwise
causes serious physical or psychological
harm
to another human or an animal okay so
you can
already see i feel like i don't even
need to explain this that thoroughly
why this is completely ridiculous once
you start saying the government
should tell us what art we should watch
what video games we should play what
books we can read what movies
we can go to you are opening a pandora's
box where the only thing that any of us
will be allowed to do is sit in a dark
room and stew in our own juices
and that's kind of what they want from
us so maybe that's where this is all
going
it's not just that video games don't
cause violence um
it's that they are an escape as i just
said and the idea here okay we're
hum you can't have human on human
violence okay goodbye
call of duty i mean goodbye virtually
every game i mean so what do you say so
star wars games because you got a wookie
killing an ewok is that all right or
that's too much or you can have cartoon
violence
like it's all just this is all just
humans
trying to manage the human mind and it's
simply not possible now
in their defense because i will give the
devil his due
i had never this is a fact i had never
eaten
magic psychotropic mushrooms before i
played
super mario brothers okay so i got super
mario brothers i was nine years old it
was 1985
and my buddy john got he was the first
one to get 8-bit nes nintendo
entertainment system
and we saw mario eating mushrooms and i
had never eaten
magical psychotropic psilocybin
mushrooms
until that point i waited about 10 years
and then when i was in college i did
try magic mushrooms is that directly
related to mario
eating the mushrooms i don't know i
don't know
sonic the hedgehog i played a lot of
sonic the hedgehog
i don't want to tell you what i did
after uh playing sonic the hedgehog you
know what i mean
okay we've all made mistakes in life but
all right i think you guys got my point
this is this is all just silliness and
if you're watching this and you like to
play video games play video games
but but don't blow up cars don't steal
things and punch hookers
i think that that suffices i don't think
we need a bill
to say that but you know these people
they just want to manage
every little part of your life when you
can go out
who you can talk to what you can say
online
how many people can be at the restaurant
you eat what type of people can be at
your house
can we track you all the time to see if
you've gotten the vaccine
are we gonna make sure that you play
mario brothers while sitting on a couch
and not a chair
like it's all just like endless
silliness and
and speaking of endless silliness uh
this woman
rachel levine this is uh president joe
biden's
transgender health and human services
pick
uh well a tweet from her from about a
year ago it's from january of last year
has come out and it's got some people
kind of raising their eyebrows going
what exactly is going on here so i want
to throw to the tweet
and it's it's pretty interesting here
this is as i said just about a year ago
dr rachel levine now secretary levine
a new study has found that transgender
youth with
access to a puberty blocker have decline
in chances of suicide and mental health
problems now and in the future this
study is important because it's the
first to show this specific association
let's leave the tweet up for just a
second
first off i just hate people that use
the hashtags that way it's like you're
mocking yourself
hashtag transgender hashtag mental
health that's a little insider baseball
uh for you on the uh on the twitter side
of things uh but interesting so in
essence what she's saying
is that young children should have
access to puberty blockers
if they feel they are trans okay
now we can have all sorts of debates
about when
when and if children should be allowed
to do this do they
what age they should be at uh i would
highly recommend
that you check out my interview from
about two months ago with abigail
schreier who wrote a book
called irreversible damage where she
uses
data and facts to show you that there
there is actually an epidemic of
young girls it's mostly young girls
transitioning to being boys and they're
doing at increasingly younger ages
and then there are all sorts of regrets
there are all sorts of medical problems
there are all sorts of psychological
problems
now all of this as i always say is is in
no way an attack on the trans community
it is no way on
an attack on anyone who wishes to live
their life as they see
fit which i would always defend as long
as they're doing it within the laws of
the united states obviously
um but the idea that the person
that is the assist what is she the
assistant the health and
health and human services uh pick
dr rachel i mean that that this is an
idea that they're going to be pushing
that younger and younger people
should transition that we should give
these people
puberty blockers this is seriously
dangerous we've got a quote here from
the national pulse
a professor of pediatrics and psychiatry
at the penn state college of medicine
levine has given lectures in various
settings since at least
2012 on how to perform sex changes
and gender conversion therapy on
children
according to levine children ought to be
given the latitude
to choose their own gender levine has
advised adults
to try not to force them one way or
one way or other and instead to follow
the child's lead
that is deeply dangerous now i don't
care that rachel levine is trans
i don't care it is irrelevant now it's
obviously why
she got the job right because we love
diversity right we've got our gay
secretary of transportation and pete
budaj does he have any
knowledge of transportation it's
irrelevant he's gay and we've got our
trans health woman over here okay
let's put the identity politics behind
what i don't like are her
ideas the quote that i just read right
there that instead of it being up to the
adults
we should follow the child's lead you
know that part of growing up in life
is sort of figuring out what the world
is and how you feel things and how those
things that you feel kind of match up to
the world
and that in many cases there are you
might feel something when you're five
years old and not feel it when you're
12.
and in some cases get this guys you're
going to think something at 18 that you
won't think when you're 44.
it's really crazy but the idea that you
would not that
you would take the the capacity for the
decision making
about something that's like basically
the most extraordinarily large
existential issue that a person that a
potentially trans person
could face and you would say oh the
five-year-old should decide that
one of the other things about this that
people don't really understand is how
these are the same people who love to
tell you that they're pro-gay right
they're pro-gay people
but really what are they saying so now
you've got a five-year-old
who happens to be effeminate let's say
happens to be effeminate and likes
playing with barbies
instead of g.i joes now first off the
parents get a whole bunch of social cred
right if they have a
trans child so they're going to sort of
feel like oh now they're going to get
some sort of value in this crazy
intersectional
olympics that is being played all the
time so they're going to kind of push
their child to do it but what you may
actually have
when you have say an effeminate boy is
just an effeminate boy who perhaps will
turn out to be gay
and if gay is okay which that's what
well certainly what i believe but it's
also
what the lefties and the wokesters are
always telling us
well then it's perfectly fine to be an
effeminate gay boy
and it's certainly fine to be say a
butch
uh young girl right like we shouldn't be
caring about all these stereotypes but
when she
says when when rachel levine who i'm
using her
preferred pronoun says oh we should
leave it up to the child well the child
is going okay i'm i have these parts i
like to play barbie
i can i can just become a girl like not
having any clue
of the of the problems the medical
procedures the money
the psychological stuff all of those
things but we should follow what the
child says about this thing and not what
the parents say
and i would say this is just consistent
with the sort of ridiculous
woke equity policies that that this
government is throwing at us
and i do think that as i said yesterday
more and more people are just going to
start basically checking out
of society in a certain way more and
more people are just going to be getting
off the machines
figuring out how to educate their
children's take care of their families
defend their property and things like
that
because the the thing the thing itself
ain't working anymore
right like the thing itself any given
day wear masks don't wear masks stay in
your house don't stay in your house
transition your child don't play video
games
it's all like it's this weird cocktail
of lunacy
that we're all we're all negotiating
with all the time this is actually very
much what my
what my neck my next book is going to be
at which i'm working on right now okay i
want to do one more for you
uh and this is going to be the throwback
i am going to keep trying to do these
because i think
it helps us frame the present when we
look to the past
uh so ron paul libertarian tea party guy
ron paul who i had on the show about a
month ago
uh he was on the uh
wait what show oh this was on the morton
county junior show i was going to say
the
the mori show no this is morton county
junior show back in the mid 80s if you
don't remember morten downey jr if
you're if you're a little younger than
an old-timer like me this
you gotta after this on youtube just
google morton downey jr show
this show was wild there was this guy
here these really big
teeth and he was very loud and very
boisterous and angry sort of a precursor
to trump in a certain way
and he would chain smoke on the show all
the time and he'd bring on all sorts of
people to yell at each other and they'd
argue about race and they'd argue about
politics
and the audience would be screaming like
in many ways the reason i was gonna
say it was the more show is like the
maury show became this thing about oh
who's the baby's daddy kind of thing
and then you know there was uh all the
all the other daytime
talk shows and jerry springer show
people come out and punching each other
in many ways this guy morton downey jr
he was the father to that so he was on
at the same time that phil donahue was
on
donahue was sort of the respected one
and then there was morton downey jr it
was more the clownish one you might
think of as as the trump
of the situation anyway he at times
would have these
really really great political debates
and i remember watching this stuff as a
kid so this clip that i'm about to show
you has been going viral last couple
days
and i want you to listen to ron paul
and not only because he's saying the
exact same things that he still says now
but you tell me
if you think basically what he's saying
is right or completely crazy and then
just watch like the
beautiful back and forth there's such a
great moment here all right take a look
ask me why we still finance the
communists ask me why 70
of the military budget is spent overseas
ask me why the good airplanes are
overseas and the lousy airplanes are
not here in the the lossy airplanes are
in this air national guard
i would say clean out the state
department spend more money on our
national defense
have an anti-communist uh policy don't
sign these treaties with the soviet
don't extend loans to the soviet union
and not to fight these wars with the
funds we raised from the illegal drugs
so under the libertarian society no we
don't fight vietnam wars we don't fight
the korean wars
we fight wars to defend america
[Applause]
excuse me yes we get high we get high
mark
we get high on the ideas of freedom
bring it high because
[Applause]
freedom
let me answer that just say no assume
the responsibility of yourself don't
assume that government makes your
[Music]
decisions
his voice changing maybe his cojones are
getting smaller
no nose against drugs it's a program
geared primarily down to kindergarten
we do it through music a cartoon
character called little no no the drug
fighter
no one else in the united states is
giving us a hand is a tyrannical
approach to solving a social medical
problem and we endorse the idea of
voluntarism and self-responsibility
family friends and churches to solve a
problem
rather than saying some monolithic
government is going to make you take
care of yourself and be a better person
it's a preposterous notion it never
works
it never will the government can't make
you a better person it can't make you
follow good habits why don't they put
you on a diet you're a little overweight
and i think you'd be in better
healthcare
you're a little trouble you know i'm
tired of people like you i'm the
government
i'm tired of people like you using the
constitution
to do whatever you want to do if we
legalize drugs we're giving up on the
whole country
[Music]
god there's there's so much great stuff
there that line
uh where he basically tells the fat guy
to lose a little weight that the
government can't do it i mean it's just
perfect the the woman at the end there
i'm tired of people like you using the
constitution in this bad way
anyway i i thought there's a lot there
because it's like people were emotional
they're screaming you know we're always
told that things are so much worse now
and we're more afraid and
it kind of feels like that because of
social media everything else but we've
always been afraid these are always the
big issues of our time but
the interesting stuff there is at the
beginning you can see how consistent he
is
right like he's absolutely consistent
with his beliefs 30 years later get out
of wars he wants to end the drug war now
the funny thing is they're they're all
chanting just say no which was the
policy obviously of nancy reagan at the
time ronald reagan
was president now i i lay this out in my
book i i'm for decriminalization of most
drugs but i don't
want to decriminalize say meth or other
hardcore drugs
i would prefer not to be putting people
in jail for these things if you sell
them
then i think there's something else but
i i personally
don't take the pure pure libertarian
approach on this i've debated
debated this by the way uh several times
with michael malus i don't want a meth
lab
next door to me right um and i by the
way i fully understand the libertarian
arguments on this but the point is in
essence what ron paul is saying is there
are there are psychological problems
there are personal problems there are
problems about dependency
but these are things to deal with in
your family as he says
in your church in your local community
things like that we shouldn't
be just saying to the government oh can
you fix
all of my problems if only that thing
out there that's not really good at
anything but it's above me if only that
could tell me what to do
i would be a better person so i just
love the fact that 30 years ago these
debates were being had and by the way
nobody
as far as i know nobody got violent in
that clip and maybe we do need some more
shows like this it was actually making
me think
once this pandemic
whatever you want to call it at this
point once this thing ends maybe i
should be doing a studio show and we'll
get people in from both sides and people
can start screaming at each other and as
long as nobody's violent
we'll we'll have some fun with it
because maybe we do need a little bit a
little bit more of that
uh anyway guys oh uh part two of my
interview with stephen crowder just went
up this morning crowder was actually
banned from twitter
yesterday he's back on today but most of
our interview for the hour
with him and his lawyer bill richmond
is about their ongoing lawsuit with
facebook
uh and the fact that he got banned from
twitter yesterday because he just did a
video
on what he claims is some pretty rock
solid evidence of voter fraud
did i just get booted from youtube while
saying it did the whole channel just
black out am i talking to nobody right
now i guess we'll find out in a minute
um so i think you'll find it really
interesting and we get into the
the you know do you want the free market
to solve these things
issues do we get into the do you just uh
leave it
to competition do you get the government
involved is it
a problem because you had a sort of more
friendly government to our ideas a few
months ago
now it's worse with the biden
administration we get into all that
stuff it's it's super interesting part
two is up now
the full episode is already up at
reubenreport.locals.com
that's all i got for you today have a
great day everybody
and uh stay sane it's gonna be all right